how's it going bros and welcome to
legend of the brofist with me
it also features some of my YouTube
friends jacksepticeye cry
markiplier cinnamon toast ken and of
course my girlfriend cutiepiemarzia they
all did voice acting for this game and
it's amazing oh yeah
this is gonna be so easy yeah about that
jet fuel is kind of expensive thanks for
the rescue
let me help you why I and I will guide
you through this place you bros have
been a huge party making this game you
decided what enemies there should be in
the game what are the characters and you
even name the game Shannon what are you
doing here I am so proud of this game
outer Minds the developers just did an
amazing job and I can't wait to hear
what you bros think about it because
this game really is for you bro wait I'm
getting you out of here
jump on my jet your what my arch-nemesis
the barrel king has contained all my
friends I captured all your pants and
soon the legendary bro face shall be
mine so join me on this epic adventure
to save the bro what are you doing in a
place like this
I'm on a quest to stop those damn
barrels the game is available right now
on iOS or Android devices so check it
out what are you waiting for I'll see
you in the game and as always stay out
great and your video to upload